das sind bilder wie ganz thailand
hoffnung machen
sie zeigen die seit tagen
eingeschlossenen spieler einer
jugendfußballmannschaft die in die
kamera schauen und mit angehörigen und
einsatzkräften sprechen
augenscheinlich geht es den jungen gut
nach heftigen regenfällen waren die
jugendlichen und ihre betreuer in einer
höhle im norden thailands verschollen
britische taucher hatten die jungen im
alter von elf bis 16 jahren und ihren
trainer am späten montagabend den
inneren der höhle mehr als drei
kilometer vom haupteingang entfernt
entdeckt die meisten von ihnen hätten
leichtere gesundheitsprobleme hieß es
ihn seien medikamente und energie drinks
gegeben worden
ein arzt blieb bei der gruppe nach
angaben der rettungskräfte werden nun
verschiedene wege geprüft die jungen aus
der hülle zu holen man könne sie in
begleitung von rettungstauchern aus dem
überfluteten teil der höhle heraus
schwimmen lassen eine andere möglichkeit
wäre weitere höhlen öffnung zu finden
zudem soll versucht werden das wasser so
weit wie möglich aus der höhle
herauszupumpen
wie lange die rettung dauert ist unklar
berichte die von mehreren monaten
gesprochen hatten wurden von den
behörden zurückgewiesen